[Music]
it's basically bikini season all year
between the gorgeous um beaches and the
tropical temperatures people spend a lot
of time outdoors but not very much um
especially here at Brazil's most famous
Beach Copacabana it's pretty obvious why
people call this place see and be seen
exercise and Diet aren't the only ways
people here shape their bodies more
cosmetic surgeries are done in Brazil
than anywhere else in the world in 2013
almost one-and-a-half million people
here went under the knife to get a look
stay well
I've come to Rio de Janeiro to get a
peek into the world of plastic surgery
actually a turn loved people here are
pretty open about it
Joseph is Jackie is Maria we can apply
silicone
[Applause]
Oh stage tastes odd men always choose
woman with bigger breasts or they have a
smoking hot body could here's my zombie
voltage babe you can make it your my
simple coochie blue that's all right
leggo I'd like to go in the know so
close and maybe some big boobs because
sometimes you are afraid of do it and
then you see your friends doing and they
are good so you go in
of all the women I talked to only one
told me she'd prefer to stay on Metro by
now I should probably know better but
I'm still surprised to see so many young
women in the waiting room of a plastic
surgeon's office one of them is either a
23 year old pharmacy student she saved
up for two years to get her surgeries a
breast augmentation here and the PO
suction at another clinic either she
went to two different doctors because it
was cheaper today doctor hoses is
checking up on how she's healing
you follow it yourself it's a pathologic
time touch face as we talk about the
three-year town I bid on me sing such
fate up a token bang sing to the potato
cause dish poet AIESEC in the North all
they talk about getting surgery as if it
were like having a cup of coffee but
what if something goes wrong it's very
common here in Brazil especially in Rio
that girls come with this illusion of
profession they want the big breasts and
it wants to be pretty just like the
girls on TV on the movies if she she
talks to me like oh I want to have the
biggest breasts or I wants to be perfect
I'm gonna tell her is this relaxed
nobody reach perfection perfection
doesn't exist but if I can hook make her
look better with surgery with low risk
then I think it's okay to do it
these ish isn't anorexic but she has set
herself some high goals she doesn't want
to show me photos but already before her
Lippo suction she managed to lose 30
kilos she works out every day together
with her husband Volker today's her
first day back at the gym since her
operations
thankful people know London expel the
same car mice quantum eyes on my lip
onto my so train my soul care Segawa the
human loss the so many Tashia taha leggo
my kago said help the Kurdish body look
at the people in Africa through Coronel
you're a mess of my poison I think you
conferred on multiplayer Goodell via
[Music]
since our surgeries either she loves to
go shopping with her cousin Layla
she says finding the right bikini used
to be torture but all that's changed now
she's got three hundred twenty
milliliters of silicone in each breast
about the size of a coke can
she is the wear size small now she's
excited to try on a large but Layla
can't find a bikini she's happy with I
think Layla looks great but she doesn't
agree would you do the surgery also to
keep them up cause it's mean friendly
okay so when you look into the mirror
how do you see yourself from my face
with bangs
crazy answer C or your possible time
tamerica Caillou - got me - no nose ever
if you're happy then why do you want to
do another another in the production
poor here comes our fees Oh got it
Norfolk oh but I mean Daisuke Tang amok
with the key me see the key sounds like
a fish nada más usted ok hapara
okay oh I should go
on our way to the beach the girls teach
me some essential Brazilian vocabulary
strapless bikini tops are called
tamerica kiya literally I hope it falls
down and I have to admit they do look
like they could fall down at any moment
and it gets even better
they call the bottom part dental floss
that's pretty funny
but I do wonder if I had to walk around
in dental floss most of the time would I
want surgery - oh if said - so you gone
way to cope via pariah time which will
undo the seaming by I show properties
and Oh SoCo push Uganda comment on do I
get thing which is also the reason why
you do all these surgeries oh I live for
my particular same freakish fuzzy there
is a huge concern Sabre Kiefer they
always say Oh is a protease if I pull
necessity idea for hearing my greasy
mojito
we say I shake I don't ferocity you
think scene accessorize the fight there
my whole body started a la mulana friend
to do - was always saying mice for a
more physical sample occasion
the girls asked me who else is going to
be on the show so I show them a picture
of Antonia from Sweden so we see when
you talk about ella ella Binet
la Aguada profit of the money Jim I'm
gonna steal and I'm st. pitifully
marketing people with anorexia always
see themselves differently than others
in your own perception you're fat even
if you're thin so it's a self perception
it's exactly the same as I will tell you
or I will tell you I think your breasts
look beautiful you will not really
because you think they're not they have
to be bigger it's the same I think it's
the same same
I want to look like this ya know I
should go for the onion my son liked it
idiot either Schwantz lady like these
women on Instagram a lot of women in
Brazil even get testosterone injections
for more muscular times
and speaking of thighs either SH has an
appointment with the surgeon who did
really po suction she wants to get some
touch-ups done dr. Kastrup says he'll do
the next operation when she's done
healing she's perfect no she's very nice
girl had her weight her body her skin
everything's okay but when she took out
the clothes we see her intimately what
she's complaining so we're looking and
you know that she's have the right of
her complaints she's had a bit fat here
a bit fat there bit fat here that fat
there it's not so much of course her
body's not completely out of the place
she's okay but should have something
that can make her body really bad
a little fat here a little fat there for
dr. Castro it's all in a day's work
after two pregnancies the young woman on
the operating table wants to have a
flatter belly it's a surgery lots of
women in Rio do dr. Castro cuts out a
part of her abdominal wall and sews the
muscles back together a little tighter
[Music]
it's one of the most horrifying scenes
I've ever witnessed
to a skinny she had almost no fat she
just said gesture kids
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just as I'm getting ready to leave
Brazil Carnival is taking over it is the
event of the year there's drinking and
dancing and needless to say people's
bodies are very much in focus
everywhere you look it's blocking that's
what these tweet parties are called
[Music]
so how is it different now that it's the
first carnival after the surgery that
you are celebrating here outside oh it
would have been his authority
Lily gave Minami
[Laughter]
when I look at everyone dancing around
me now I can't help but wonder who's had
what surgery and what they might have
looked like before
which role does the summer play in this
presentation of the body and idea of
having you know polygamy the seleção
it leaves me kind of torn I do
understand why either she wants to
change her body there doesn't seem to be
any reason not to when everyone else
around you is doing it it might sound
naive but I wish we could be confident
enough to accept our bodies instead of
trying to push perfection to the limit